stick around to the end of this video to
see the top 5 coolest and best things
you missed in its 2017 before we get
into the top 5 things you missed in its
let me tell you about the worst one in
this deleted scene if you zoom into the
movie theater marquee you can loosely
make out the title of the 1988 film
imagine me but what's interesting is
what you'll actually find in an infamous
scene from that movie
[Music]
so guys we did it we reached a quarter
of a million subscribers that was a
terrible name but genuinely genuinely
thank you for supporting me thank you
for sitting through this name and yeah
here's the actual video number five
references to locations from the book
Stephen King's novel it's comes in at
over eleven hundred pages long making it
impossible to fit every scene into the
adaptation many of the scenes that were
not included are referenced via Easter
eggs like the intersection of which
amande Jackson where Georgie loses an
arm which is also the exact spot at home
in the old Derry Township was burned to
the ground in 1741 try kerberos truckin
was a truck Depot where the kids have
dairy like to play baseball which Eddie
revisits and faces manifestations of it
as an adult Benz school project is the
daily stand pipe and when he drops it it
becomes dislodged from the ground this
is where stan has his first encounter
with it and the location where some kids
had drowned in dairies past then can
also briefly be seen going through
Memorial Park which is adjacent to the
standpipe and a victim of its name's
Steven Johnson turns up there in the
adult Sara Beverly's father works
maintenance at the dairy home hospital
where many residents of Derry were born
and were the younger brother of Edward
Corcoran dies Ritchie sports his shirt
from Freese's department store a
business that he runs into in the book
to take refuge from an angry Henry
Bowers the black spot is briefly touched
on in the movie it was a nightclub that
was burned down by an evil cult in
Gary's past that brings me to another
tragedy of old Gary number four the
bradley gang mural as the losers try to
get some medical supplies for been he
and Richie's stay out in the alley where
there's a huge mural depicting one of
the stories told about in
he's passed in the novel the Bradley
gang was a group of gangsters wanted for
bank robbery and murder who had come to
Derry in 1929 practically the whole town
came together to shoot up the gangs car
and witnesses recall a circus clown
joining in on the carnage
although Pennywise isn't initially seen
in the painting it has the ability to
manipulate the town and shortly after
the clown can be seen watching them in
the alleyway
speaking of clowns there are a lot of
secrets hidden in number three the clown
room Ricci wanders into this room inside
twenty nine niebolt Street where he's
faced with his worst fear I've already
discussed this reference to the TV
mini-series adaptation of it but in
addition to that there's a clown statue
that turns its head this picture that I
just find particularly creepy and the
model that rich he finds himself which
matches his earlier prediction about
what happened to Betty rips up you think
they'll actually find her sure a ditch
all decomposed covered in worms and
maggots smell like a tease mom's
underwear
number two the turtle millions of years
ago when it was created by a celestial
force known as the other another entity
was also created and this was the turtle
essentially the rival of its the turtle
subtly pops up here and there in the
book to help the losers Club and there
are a couple of similar references in
the movie like the lego turtle that bill
finds in Georgie's room the model of the
walkie talkies they use trtl 500 and the
turtle that touches Richards foot in the
quarry number one the cosmic origins of
EDS this isn't really explored in the
movie but the novel alludes to its and
the turtle being the original
inhabitants of an outer dimensional void
known as the macro virus and in one
scene we see each crash landing on earth
from outer space however fans of the
book will be pleased to see some small
nods to its cosmic origins like the
solar system set up in bill's room the
reach for the stars poster in the
library the Moon poster and Globes scene
in Ben's room the alien spaceship found
in Georgie's room and Ben's shirt during
the projector and niebolt scenes these
is in the top five things you missed in
it if you want to see the full 94 things
you missed click the video on the left
and remember to subscribe to seize these
worlds for new Horrors every week bring
the DEATH BATTLE for notifications and
see you in the next one assuming we both
survive